Nick Sandman the smiling target of the
infamous Covington smear is suing the
Washington Post for 250 million bucks
for leading the media mob can't say I
blame him because the story isn't about
Covington but those who covered it not
to mention all the money they made off
that smear this case along with
Cavanaugh and small acts and a hundred
others need to be a journalism course
one that reveals how echo chamber media
gins up outrage protects narratives and
steers social media into a frenzy we
blame Twitter but Twitter's just the
wall the media throws stuff at to see
what sticks if it sticks you make a lot
of money or use it to build the
reputations of some left wing hacks
Nick's lawsuit means that in the future
some dope can't brag to the Pulitzer
committee that he broke the Covington
story
remember the Clarence Thomas hearings
and how that turned many liberals like
Andrew Breitbart into fire-breathing
conservatives sometimes a show trial
reveals more than you think
Feinstein traded her reputation for a
shot at Kavanagh
since 2016 those epiphany moments like
Covington have piled up in mere months
we've seen three major media fails there
are others but there's only one
persistent culprit at the crime scene
the mainstream media journalists who are
writing for other journalists hoping to
get a better job a book deal a prize a
minute on TV and the motivating factor
behind the Machine conflict conflict
leads to eyeballs which leads to cliques
which leads to money yeah the media made
tons off Covington so why should the kid
get a piece of the action after all
without poor Nick some of us would have
to work for a living
so Jesse I thought had the brain room do
some research did you know that the
watch my move yes I know you know that
the Washington Post digital ad revenue
for 2017 was a solid nine figures that's
over a hundred million dollars so that's
how they make it yeah hey cells yeah
yeah hate is Division cells yes I did
enjoy reading The Washington Post report
about how the Washington Post is bad
because they got sued that was fun I
so don't think it matters whether they
win this lawsuit this is just a big blow
to fake news because right now every
newsroom and all the executives this is
coming from the top down they're telling
the editors and the reporters do not
shoot first and ask questions yeah it's
better to be late and right than first
and wrong because right now they're
facing ruinous lawsuits and it takes the
penalty of a financial hit for them to
change their behavior because they're
not policing themselves you pointed out
there's fake news is getting worse
yeah so the only thing to do is hold
them accountable to account because they
like to hold other people account like
us like us and they never ever have to
look inward so there's a good I mean
you're so deep in the front bunker
sometimes I think I gotta help Jesse out
because I'd be buried let me just tell
you something one reporters if their
opinion and somebody's opinion about
Nick is now the subject of a loss not to
pay imagine what you would be up against
with my smirk - jesse is never on
Twitter you never on Twitter know it's
done you know but it wasn't no
Washington Post it wasn't NBC it wasn't
any media outlet this was started by a
website that was intending to somehow
divide the American people and with the
Washington Post they have to do due
diligence they have to fact-check they
have to check all this I use they have
to investigate they hope read the
lawsuit all the other side didn't
investigate the video they kept on
printing malicious smears this guy about
things that never happen what police he
never chanted anything derogatory he
never said build a wall you never said
anything racist one what you are deep
into a political tribal argument the
fact is here this is a Julia suit it
should be dismissed well it's really an
insult let me but I will say this it's
part of an attack on the print yeah we
ever seen any time you criticize
she can't be criticized give me a shot
because what did we see today President
Trump is saying the New York Times is
the enemy of the people why because the
New York Times did a story that said he
asked the acting Attorney General don't
worry one problem oh that's what's going
on here Emily's a lawyer Emily tell me
about what you think this is this case
250 million too much or not enough
well they the reason that they are
seeking 250 million is because that's
the amount that Bezos purchased the
Washington Post for 2013 so what kind of
I liked that homage I will say one to
your point just now that I think that's
exactly that
unfortunately invalid argument that is
being made which is pointing to the
president's rhetoric in defense of this
that's exactly the point the lawsuit
makes and Internet answer your question
yes what you just said they what matters
or the heart of the lawsuit is whether
wopo negligence negligently published
this information in reckless disregard
of the actual truth or do they actually
have malice right not if he's a private
the fact that for example in the lawsuit
it details that there were seven
articles and three tweets and it listed
all of the headlines and it listed the
13 million followers on Twitter that
that amplification process it is is what
is reasonably foreseeable and that
lawsuit is basically saying look you you
know maybe in the first time if you
repeat a headline that's one thing but
there were multiple multiple things
where you were characterizing this minor
child at the time in an extremely drug
Ettore way and it wasn't exact reporting
and it was a rally he was in a public
place at the Lincoln Memorial he was
engaged in the expression of his
opinions and his we go to break going
after the seatpost they're going after
CNN their body celebrities Dana how are
you enjoy listening to the conversation
a couple things
lawsuit will probably be dismissed upon
the first hearing and if the first
motion to dismiss I think the judge
applied rules that way
but are they making a good point yes and
it gets to a broader one which we've
talked about this before which is when
for example a media company you said
it's digital edge sales
yes the other thing that they're getting
out of that is your data right so what
you're looking at what you buy what you
want what restaurants you're gonna go to
all of that stuff the question has been
should you get a piece of that like that
do you own some of that so then took my
bigger picture point I get it is do you
own your conflict exactly that is the
genius moment of this show we depute if
you are an object in this conflict you
desert you're the actor do you deserve a
role do deserve a payment for the roles
European v conflict' it's not that
they're the the agent the actor owns the
data and here we don't but I agree and
also that larger point that at what
point do we hold accountable the media
outlets that are literally via the
public mob capitalizing on it and then
ruining reputations forever oh so what
do you do about Donald Trump today he
says go get him Nick because much law
policy he's cheering him on because he
sees this as evidence that the media is
after him I want to check I want to know
my whole thing has always been the same
I believe that this is a consensus media
in which the profit model is conflict
and you got to put a check on it and if
this doesn't it to me it doesn't matter
if you get some money you just got to
make them think I just want only America
wants it's they just want the media to
think before they where'd the tape come
from what they come from mainstream
media it didn't edit it you guys took
all the random vs random BS you spit it
out there and put a bunch of lies in it
that's what you did I think conservative
websites that spread conspiracy theories
are far more prevalent than anything
blew it and then you wanted me